dr. James Andrews is the founding
partner medical director for the Andrews
Institute in Gulf Breeze Florida he's
been recognized internationally with
contributions in knee shoulder elbow
injuries orthopedic surgeon team
position for the Redskins Auburn
University also on University of
Alabama's medical staff as a consultant
and doctor thanks for joining us on
short notice we appreciate it my
pleasure to be here
give me the athlete if he calls right
now that you would have to hang up the
phone on me what there's no what kind of
trouble they were in but I'm constantly
switching from telephone the telephone
with the second towel so you know one of
my big deals and sports medicine is is
availability answer the telephone well I
wanted to have you on I know that you
did Drew Brees his shoulder surgery
years ago when he got hurt but
quarterbacks in general when it comes to
these surgeries you got Andrew Luck who
you did not operate on in Cam Newton who
I don't believe you operated on either
they're coming back from torn labrum and
I think rotator cuff it feels like the
shoulder is still something that we're
not quite sure what your what you're
going to get when you have that surgery
where it feels like we perfected the
knee surgery you do elbows knees and
shoulders which one's the toughest one
to handicap of how somebody will come
out of it
well when I walk in the room and seeing
over here throwing athlete and if it's
his elbow I'm relieved if it's the
shoulder
I'm worried so we still have a long ways
to go with the throwing shoulder
relative to having to operate on them
and get them well in the healing
response and how long it takes them to
come back just like the rainbow it's all
over the place so the big thing about
the show is you can't rush him but you
go back to what drew brees had why was
he feels like he's even better than he
was prior to the surgery why is that
because he's drew brees I'll tell it's
not letting up the two things that
should take credit for his successes one
has normal ability in his motivation and
work ethic and the physical therapist
kevin wilt that did his rehab in
Birmingham what I did when I was just
along for the ride if you want to know
the truth drue State in Birmingham for
like four months working out twice a day
almost day all day long doing rehab with
Kevin Wilk and that's really why he got
back if you look at a torn labrum or
you're going to repair the rotator
Andrew Luck has won Cam Newton the other
one which one tell me the difference
between those two as far as recovery
time well it's about the same but you
know I really don't have I don't know
either one of those players so I'm
really ESSEC Lee I'm really not able to
respond about how long it's going to
take them to get back it wouldn't be
fair to them nor to their team but if
you know it varies as to how quick they
can recover but it's not it's not weeks
it's it's nuts and sometimes it's it's
into the season so you just don't know
the main thing is I said earlier is you
can't rush him and you got to let them
have time to mature the shoulder and get
over the surgery and and hopefully was
it was a minor situation where they can
get back and play this season which was
I have no idea otherwise which one's
worse though torn labrum or a rotator
the rotator cuff is the granddaddy of
shoulder injuries now the one that has
probably the worst connotation that you
hear about is the labrum and we have a
hard time figuring out what to do with
the labrum whether should we clean it up
should we prepare it should we ignore it
but a lot of throwers have labral
pathology without symptoms so you have
to really be careful how you read that
the knee surgery now as opposed to 20
years from now or 20 years ago like
where where are we and what do you what
do you think is going to happen with
knee surgeries but the thing with knee
surgeries is uh we come a long long ways
with knee surgery and the thing to
revolutionize knee surgery of course was
there
scope the problem we're having with new
surgeries now knee injuries particularly
in the NFL is the wear patterns we're
getting on the articular cartilage
surfaces which is an overuse wear
pattern they get them from years of
playing football and that's the big
problem now is trying to figure out how
do we fix these cartilage so called
cartilage lesions in the weight-bearing
surfaces of the knee joint
you know the ACL is still a problem
obviously but we're pretty consistent
with getting ACLs back we're not a
hundred percent though the problem with
ACL surgeries is eight nine ten years
later most of them have developed some
arthritic change related back to the
injury so it's not something that's you
like to have but it can't be a problem
is with wear patterns even when you've
done a successful ACL reconstruction do
you think you know it's always something
that we have to worry about in the knee
but we've come a lot further in the knee
and we have in the shoulder or even the
elbow do you think there will be a
pre-emptive surgery for athletes in the
future preventative not that I know of
my role is that's not anything we can
make better with surgery better than the
good Lord made it so I doubt if that's
ever going to come to pass the big
problem the big thing is trying to
figure out how do we prevent the
injuries to begin with with just basic
rule changes and and preventative
exercises and not playing one sport and
specializing in a sport well months out
of the year
where you stand on little leaguers in
you know how they throw how often they
throw because you I'm sure I've seen a
lot of these elbow injuries and you've
seen them with now younger and younger
children so a lot of parents listening
to this program is there some kind of
words of advice from you know one of the
great surgeons in history that could
help us well that's certainly a problem
that I see daily I did three times
John's yesterday on either freshman in
college our young high school
this morning I've been seeing new
patients and so far I've had three rooms
I've been to seeing new patients they're
all 15 16 17 years of age that are
playing year-round baseball and it
injured their Tommy John's ligament so
the big thing for parents is they
anybody doing an overhead throwing
sports should have at least two months
off preferably three to four months off
each year when they're not doing an
overhead sport which means it shouldn't
specialize in play twelve months out of
the year but then one thing I can tell
them if they if they're playing and
they're playing with fatigue in youth
baseball meaning they have to take
seasonal fatigue or year-round fatigue
if they're doing that there's a 36 to
one times
that's a 3,600 percent increased chance
of injuring the shoulder or their elbow
play them youth baseball so fatigue is
the thing we have to prevent it so how
do we do that that's the big question I
know you're busy
I always appreciate your time and thank
you doctor we appreciate you and
especially with that piece of advice
there for parents of kids who are
playing high score youth baseball thank
you doctor well well thank you for
getting the message out and good luck to
all these football players this year
Thank You doc that's dr. James Andrews
found a partner medical director for the
Andrews Institute Gulf Breeze Florida
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience